a flood of objections crowded his mind
the four of them hadn't been apart since
they become a crew
and splitting the group now felt like
bad luck the repair crew on tycho might
need him or want him
or make some change to the ship he
wouldn't know about until it became a
critical point somewhere down the line
or worse leaving might mean never coming
back
if the universe had proved anything in
these last few years
it was that nothing was certain hey guys
pete here
today i've got another expanse season 5
video
looking at some of the big changes they
made when they adapted the fifth book in
the series
story wise it's pretty faithful we get
to the same place
but there are quite a few major changes
that happen along the way
as a warning there will be spoilers in
this video if you haven't finished the
fifth season of the expanse
obviously i'll be talking about the
books but i won't be giving away any
future spoilers beyond nemesis games
with that out of the way let's get
started the story of nemesis games is
that the crew splits up in the midst of
a big shift in the power dynamic in the
system
and the individual struggles they face
trying to get back together
the challenge for season five of the
show is that most of this happens
internally
it's the first time we had point of view
chapters from amos naomi and alex
and the story is developed through their
thoughts about what's happening
it's a great way to better understand
and flesh out the individual members of
the crew
but it's not something that can be
adapted easily to the medium of
television
one big change in the show was that we
don't see much of the time on
taiko before they split up amos and alex
are already gone by the time naomi tells
jim that she's leaving
in the part that's cut out we get our
first look inside
alex and amos's heads because the ship's
gonna be getting repairs that'll take a
long time
alex thinks about going back to mars and
as you can tell from the excerpt i
opened the video with he's prone to
worry
and we see how that translates into his
position
as the sort of glue that keeps the crew
together
amos gets a message from eric and he
learns that lydia has died
that means he's got to go back to earth
and we see that he has
feelings of sadness and grief that he
has a hard time identifying he initially
thinks he might be getting sick because
he's got an
empty feeling in his chest and a lump in
his throat
in a way this is the first confirmation
we have that amos experiences these
kinds of feelings
he's a character that's hard to read
since he always wears the same kind of
amiable smile
regardless of the situation he finds
himself in we know he's lacking in
empathy
and doesn't possess some of the social
graces that we see in his crewmates
later when he gets into the fight with
the gang members on the shuttle
we learn that he finds relief in the
violence of it there was a long second
where the five thugs stared at the knife
on the floor at amos's feet and he
stared back at them
the emptiness in his belly was gone the
hollow space behind his sternum
gone his throat had stopped hurting
who's next he said
flexing his hands his face in a grin he
didn't know he had
they came in a rush amos spread his arms
and welcomed them like long
lost lovers in their departure naomi and
holden are forced to consider the idea
that amos and alex might not return
naomi's approach is more pragmatic and
she brings up the idea that they should
think about hiring more crew
something they should have done a long
time ago holden resists the idea because
he doesn't want anything to change and
he looks at things differently because
they run the ship as a family rather
than a crew
they both agree that they were lucky to
have developed that kind of family
dynamic and that it's been able to work
so well
for so long they agree they should try
to preserve that as best they can
but they also have to be realistic
because things can happen
then she gets a message from marco which
puts things in motion for her to leave
as well that all plays out somewhat
differently in the show
for one thing marco and philip were
introduced in season 4
and we saw that they were planning
something big with the asteroid when she
gets the message from marco in the book
it's pretty much the first indication
we've had that he'll be part of the
story
in the show she made a decision to ask
fred to find phillip so that she could
make contact and try to offer him a
chance to get away from his father
after they meet phillip takes it on
himself and decides to kidnap her and
that's how she ends up on the pella
in the book marco uses philip as bait to
lure her to series
and while getting the rossi out of his
way was part of that plan
bringing naomi into the fold was also
part of it
since we have access to naomi's thoughts
in the book we learn about her past
which has always been a secret
we also learn a lot about how marco
operates
not having that same tool at their
disposal seems to tie
in with why the show decided to
introduce him earlier
nemesis games opens with a mysterious
prologue that happens a year prior to
the rossi
arriving at tycho after returning from
ellis
it's a ticking clock situation where a
group of belters are conducting a raid
on the mcrn
shipyard on the jovian moon callisto we
don't know who they are
or what they're trying to steal just
that the raid is led by a new character
named phillip
it's his first command his father is
vaguely mentioned as one of the reasons
that his men
follow him and it's his 15th birthday
this is when the free navy got their
hands on stealth tech
in the show they had them getting it on
mars as part of bobby's story there
and after this happens in the prologue
of the book we don't hear anything else
about them
this means that it's a huge surprise
when the rocks actually hit
and that's made a hundred times better
because we see it through
amos's point of view and we hear the
news report playing describing what
happens and it doesn't really catch
amos's attention
he's sitting in the waiting room of the
prison and he's passing time
thinking about what he would do if
something went wrong
and well the report that a giant
asteroid hit
earth isn't really competition for that
for him at that moment
that's one place where the book is far
superior for me
i can still remember the first time
reading it having to go back to make
sure i knew what was going on because no
one in the chapter was paying attention
all the clues that were there start to
click and you realize that naomi's son
was already complicit
in a planet level atrocity since the
crew is all spread out
we get to experience the event through
all of their different perspectives
holden has the hardest time in this
separation which we more or less saw in
the show
and the big change in his story is
something i talked about
in my last video when he meets with
monica
she brings him information about several
ships that
disappeared while transiting the ring
gates he starts to look into this before
the free navy attacks begin
several things are changed from the book
in the middle of the story as the free
navy
tried to change things in soul system
forever the attack on taiko
is not as successful because even though
fred is shot he ends up surviving
he does still die in the books but that
doesn't happen until later
the other major difference with marco's
plan is that he also
attempted to assassinate the martian
prime minister
as well this was something that i missed
seeing adapted
especially alex and the prime minister's
conversations which were a lot of fun
but overall it's not terribly important
in the scheme of things
since the breakaway fleet made their
move towards laconia with all that
martian hardware
he ends up losing the position by book 6
anyway for a brief rundown of what
happened
alex and bobby went to the hungarian
group of asteroids to check on one of
those missing ships that holden was
curious about
they end up getting chased by the free
navy just like they did in the show
and they have to dump core to get out of
it but in the book they're racing
towards a martian fleet who happen to be
transporting the prime minister
the free navy attacks the fleet and in
desperation
they have bobby and alex take him onto
the docked razorback to try to make an
escape
since it doesn't have guns the martian
ships fired nearly 90 missiles
which were assigned to the razorback's
calm lasers
so that they could be used as a kind of
defense shield so this was very cool
and it all ended with bobby riding one
of the missiles to rescue naomi which
again
was something i was hoping to see on
screen but on the show
the rescue scene came out pretty perfect
even without it
plus we also got the battle for soul
ring in the show
which added a lot to the finale in my
opinion and that didn't happen in the
books the free navy didn't go there
after leaving the chet's mocha instead
they chased after the prime minister
the biggest change from book to show is
alex's death while saving naomi at the
end
this was a big surprise for the story
since he's still alive in the books
however we knew something was coming as
the actor who plays alex
cass anvar was removed from the show
after several allegations of sexual
misconduct
the studio launched an independent
investigation
and announced his firing before season 5
came out
i've had a lot of questions about this
so i've talked about this a lot in my
recent videos
the bottom line is it's an unfortunate
situation
and because they were done filming
before the investigation started it's
noticeable that they had to alter
the original ending since this is the
original way fred dies
there is a lot of foreshadowing about
the dangers of stroking out during
hygiene maneuvers in the books
the ending is fitting for the character
alex so they did the best they could do
with what they had
but it is a very big change from the
original
the sponsor of today's video is
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creative and
curious people
explore new skills develop existing
interests and get lost in creativity
i've been taking the art of making video
trailers by olaf the floor
i really like how this course breaks
down the thought process
behind each step if you're uncertain
about what's next creative challenges
and productivity classes can be a great
way to help you structure your time and
set up achievable goals at a time when
so many important conversations are
happening in our world
your voice is more essential than ever
explore classes to unlock your
creativity for social good
skillshare offers memberships with
meaning connect with the support of
fellow creatives and enter a community
of encouragement
communication and inspiration whether
you're looking to fend off boredom focus
on self-care through creativity
or join a similarly creative community
skillshare is the place to keep you
learning the first 1000 people to use
the link in my description will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
membership
and after that it's only around ten
dollars a month
another big change from the books is the
inclusion of drummer and her
new polyamorous family story in season
five
the family situation this belter
polyamorous
marriage comes from the character michio
paw who played a large role in the third
book
and then returns in the sixth book to
play another large role
she basically took two books off the
show character of drummer absorbed parts
of michio's story in season three so
it's not terribly surprising that she
would continue that
it has been moved up to keep drummer
involved in this season though
and considering where things left it
looks like there will be some changes to
it which i can't really get into here
because that would be in future spoilers
territory
another funny change here is that bull
is based on a different character
that showdrummer absorbed in season 3.
now they brought him into the story
to replace the role that the original
book drummer played
working for fred at tycho so drummer
replaced bull
and that led to bull replacing the
original drummer
that's most of the big changes of course
there's tons of change details different
characters doing different things
and then there's some minor changes in
the show the un destroyed palestinian
that doesn't happen in the books
as i mentioned earlier the free navy
attacks soul ring and we get to see a
whole battle play out
that didn't happen in the books either
early in the season when alex went to
the war college and met with soviter
that was a change that served to
introduce the character because in the
epilogue of the book we just meet him
briefly and then he disappears when
trying to transit the ring
in the same way that happened in the
show as i mentioned in my ending
explained video
instead of meeting soviter alex met a
character named
commander duarte who we learn at the end
of the book
is now referring to himself as admiral
duarte
and he's the mastermind behind the whole
exodus of the breakaway fleet to laconia
i mentioned earlier how much more
shocking the rocks were in the books
and this is related to the other thing i
wanted to mention before i bring the
video to an end
by the time the crew is back together
there's a sense that things are much
worse on earth in the books than they
were in the show there we hear
estimates of four to seven billion dead
and there's that big of a discrepancy
because things are so chaotic that it's
hard to get an accurate count
on the other hand in the show we heard
estimates in the millions
and there we spent a lot more time with
avasarala
where things didn't seem to be as dire
this could turn out to be a big
change or it may be something that we'll
see get exponentially worse as
season 6 progresses there's really no
picking which is better between books
and the show i read the books first and
books would almost always win in that
kind of a match-up
in this particular case nemesis games is
so character focused and it relies so
much on internal dialogue
that i think that they complement each
other well in many cases where they lost
the build-up from not having that
internal aspect the show was able to
lean into crafting some beautiful scenes
that were able to deliver
and i think that's a good place to leave
it please like this video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon